what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and there seems to be a lot
of mixed opinions about the way demon
ser ended and it was pretty unique so I
thought the ending called for an
explanation of what really happened with
its own dedicated video so stay tuned
for that if you enjoy seeing demon
sailor videos on this channel and want
to keep them coming be sure to smash
that like button and share this video if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial ring that notification
bell or you will miss future demon say
your videos you can check out our huge
playlist of demon slayer videos link in
the description while we wait for the
demon slayer anime movie to come out
keep in mind you can get early access to
all of the content on this channel
including demon slayer by following our
anime out pro audio podcast links in the
description as usual there will be manga
spoilers in this video I'm talking about
the end of demon slayer after all if you
just want to chapter review of the last
chapter I have published a video already
and you can check it out there's a link
in the description but this will be a
different kind of format I won't be
going chronologically through the
chapter but rather I'll be talking about
the ending as a whole I've heard some
people on Instagram saying that they
weren't huge fans at the ending we got
they wanted more of tundra Dona Zuko's
92 and the rest rather than a chapter
about the next next next generation we
should recognize that it's impossible to
please everyone with an ending to a
popular series just look at what
happened with the Game of Thrones ending
but I will explain in this video to the
best of my ability what actually
happened with this ending to clear up
some confusion and why I personally
think it works as the ending of Demon
Slayer
in reference to the idea that we should
have gotten an ending with our main
characters I think we pretty much did
get that I said it when I reviewed
chapter 204 that that could have been a
great ending for the story it wraps
things up nicely Sanne me apologizes to
Mitsuko our guys recover and pay their
respects at the graves they return home
as humans and they eat and talk happily
into the night the war with muslem was
over and we got the happy ending for our
main characters that would have sufficed
however it also would have left some
loose ends like bitter ships come true
and did eager to ever get his wish to be
reincarnated as a human and to marry
meet suti it's nice to know that our
main characters got what they wanted but
it's pretty sad that most of the
extremely young
Pilar's experienced such painful lives
and then died fighting against Musa they
never really got their happy ending the
egora reincarnation part may be weird
for us to even imagine since we don't
really talk about reincarnation much in
the West to help ourselves understand it
better we could look to Buddhism which
has had a major influence on the Demon
Slayer story in my review of the last
chapter I mentioned karma in the
dictionary karma is defined in Hinduism
and Buddhism as the sum of a person's
actions in this and previous states of
existence viewed as deciding their fate
in future existences and quote and thus
through good actions in their present
lives people can ensure happy futures
for themselves in future reincarnations
however bad actions will have the
opposite effect because of karma people
who behave badly in this life will
suffer more in their next lives and
they're also less likely to be
reincarnated as humans they might be
reincarnated as an animal or something
else entirely
this is why ego kept specifically saying
that he wished to be reborn as a human
because within this philosophy there's
the possibility of not being reborn as a
human at all in Buddhism there is also
the possibility of escaping the cycle of
death and rebirth by achieving Nirvana
the end of all suffering we don't have
to get too much into nirvana
or enlightenment for this video but I'll
mention how it might apply to the story
and to the last chapter later on because
demon slayer takes place in a world with
reincarnation and the reincarnation was
mentioned previously in the story it
makes sense to include it in the final
chapter as if all this foreshadowing
wasn't enough for us to realize that
what we were seeing in the final chapter
were happy reincarnations yoshi taro a
descendant of zani - and a Zuko even
brings up reincarnation again saying
that he believes and I quote everyone
who fought demons and died for a
peaceful world was reborn into a happier
life and quote so the pillar lookalikes
that we see aren't just the sentence of
the pillars in fact as far as we know
most died before they could have kids so
they can't be their descendants rather
they're their reincarnation because as
yoshi taro put it
they fought demons and died for a
peaceful world they karmically
earned to live these happy lives and
have these happy endings thus it's not
just our main guys who got happy endings
everybody who earned
happy ending through their actions got
one even if it took an extra lifetime or
two to get there and even as I compare
demon sera to Buddhism keep in mind that
Demon Slayer could put its own spin on
these beliefs and it doesn't have to
follow Buddhism exactly so there's room
for interpretation and for creativity on
the mangakas part you'll notice that we
don't see any reincarnations of people
that killed humans as demons bad dudes
like moose on and upper moon to DOMA are
nowhere to be seen perhaps they got
reincarnated as bugs or something but
perhaps Demon Slayer has heaven and it's
opposite as well as reincarnation the
reason we might assume this is because
at different moments in the story like
in Chapter 156th characters talk about
heaven Jesus sensei says that uh cos are
still his son-in-law and student but he
cannot take him to heaven implying aqus
along with other demons might be going
to hell so the demon slayer world might
be a mix of different worldviews in one
along with demons some other very good
characters haven't been reincarnated as
far as we can tell for instance your
Ichi the strongest demon seer in history
only appeared in the past he didn't
appear in Punja does time or in the
present this obviously isn't because he
was bad in fact he acted like a saint
thus within the Buddhist framework
he might have achieved Nirvana or
enlightenment and escaped the cycle of
reincarnation and or he could have gone
to the heaven that akka saw sensei was
talking about chances are the
reincarnations of the pillars are gonna
end up there too after they experience
these easier and happier reincarnated
lives then there's also the question of
whether or not Punto Sonny joined the
rest of our main characters who got
their happy endings in the past were
reincarnated too it seems clear that
they were if we go off of looks and
that's one way to interpret it but upon
closer examination that's not the way I
see it
Yoshi tato was very specific with his
words he didn't say everyone who fought
demons was reborn into a happier life
but everyone who fought demons and died
was reborn thus from my perspective is I
need to soul tanjo soul and so on
probably went to the heaven that was
previously mentioned after their earthly
happy endings
while these characters we see in this
chapter are strikingly similar in
appearance to them because they are
their descendants this would explain why
some of their personalities are told
different than that of our main
characters for instance Walden Goku's
Orion carnations personality is the same
Sumi Kiko is obviously different from
tan judo since time judo was driven
while Sumi hiko seems to prioritize his
sleep above all else Meza coal was
incredibly nice to her brother while her
look-alike taco is extremely aggressive
and mean with her brother Yoshi taro
Kanata kano's look-alike is even a boy
rather than a girl he no ski was pretty
wild and loud while his descendant seems
more shy and ordinary all this stuff
seems to point to the fact that these
are not the reincarnated souls of our
main characters but different souls
altogether for these reasons it seems
that some characters went to heaven
right away while some were reborn to
happier lives and will probably
eventually break the cycle and go on to
heaven to join the others whether this
heaven is a place where your soul
maintains its individuality or
blissfully becomes one with the universe
is up for debate so that's my view on
the reincarnation stuff and who is and
is not a reincarnation lastly I did want
to mention the other reason why I
appreciated this last chapter I liked it
because as I mentioned we got to see
which ships sail if we end it off on
chapter 204 we'd have no idea if is any
to ended up with mezu KO and if tundra
ended up with Cano
especially since Connell didn't even
come with them to the family home
however in this chapter it's made clear
does any two-bit end up with mezu KO and
tantra did end up with Cano in fact if
we think back to Sumiyoshi tangelos
ancestor we can see that tangerine
Cano's descendants uma Kiko got the Sumi
part and xeni - Annette Zuko's
descendant Yoshi ter who got the Yoshi
part which I thought was really cool I
also like the descendants rather than
reincarnation 'z interpretation because
then sunny - and as Zuko can remain
eternal soul mates
along with tan John Connell in the final
chapter we also got the seed that the
oubli Isshiki family curse was in fact
broken before they would get sick and
die before the age of 30 but after
massan's defeat and oubli ishiki goes on
to become the oldest person in Japan I
loved that part but not as much as
getting to see a girl's wish come true
seeing iguras reincarnation and meet
Sora's reincarnation actually end up
together made this an epic and
for me and that's why I think this last
chapter was not only good but necessary
for the story and that is it for today's
video let me know if you gained a new
appreciation for the ending or if you
still aren't a fan of it or if you were
just always a fan like me if you enjoyed
this video make sure to smash that like
button and share this video if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial ring that notification bell or
you will miss future to even say your
videos you can check out our huge
playlist of Demon Slayer videos link in
the description while we wait for a
demon slayer anime movie to come out and
you can follow our instagram at anime
uproar a link in the description so you
don't miss any updates for the demon
center movie anime and spin-offs keep in
mind you can also get early access to
all of our content on this channel
including demon slayer by following our
anime upper audio podcast links in the
description lastly the YouTube ad rates
have significantly dropped recently so
the help and support we're getting from
our anime up or patrons is now more
important than ever a very special thank
you goes to our patrons over on patreon
who helped us survive these YouTube
issues and who helped make videos like
this one possible first and foremost I
want to thank the legend acknowledged by
Lord Twigg o himself
Efrain a and the one to your patrons the
ones who stay atop all clans steven
grata aloha Naughton the world stealers
tyson Kirino acquire respect potata
Jonathan King desi deep Rendon of miles
papa smurf emperor otaku and richie
martinez and our pro hero to your
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing about a fan Jason Wilson king
cell just Anatole Kazansky angel Cruz I
Sparky 65 cricket XP Ted no Ted Joe
Stanton very Gucci Alicia actor animal
69 jessica calif on he no commie and
water
Bonnie parks zodia R 12 with two and a
hora Tian Wong Mitch loves anime cynical
Kraken and JCCC wakka thank you all so
much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon calm
and Meowth Pro and becoming a patron
today for as little as $1 if you do so
you'll get named featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
a private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course bank
memes so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
or link in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
YouTube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see you space Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]